you have this amazing look in this film
look
at your hercules
now i have my uh first question is the
hair
is that is that your
real hair what did you what's going on
there that is not that is a wig
uh so so you know with this we had great
italian designers wig makers beard
makers uh makeup
uh scars three and a half hours every
day because the idea was to
transform into what you see and um
so the wig makers were incredible all
oscar nominated
oscar winners the beard uh was put on it
wasn't lace so it was put on
uh piece by piece uh he would cut strips
of yak hair
it was yak hair it was yak hair why why
care well i guess with yak hair it's uh
it's a bit softer it lays on your face
uh you wouldn't know that right on your
face just
nice uh and so he would cut strips of
about an inch
uh high and about quarter inch wide and
piece by piece he would put it on so as
he's putting it on i had a great uh
makeup artist his name is mateo and i
said mateo and again three and a half
hours every day i said
what is this he goes oh it's a yak hair
yeah i care he goes yeah from a yak he
goes yes from yak i said oh huh okay
what part of the yak i'm curious the
balls
the balls the balls why well that's what
i said
why the balls it's a soft
place so so so the commitment
for you people is that
is covered in yeah yeah that's rare it
that's the is that's the moment where
they told you
these are yet pubes
[Laughter]
i also noticed you're wearing the
leather sort of skirt
uh yes and i'm curious how's that
how is it wearing a skirt uh is it a
skirt is that correct is it a loins
no it's on the loins good loincloth
loincloth is what we call it in the
streets of 350 bc
yeah yes it's a blowing claw hey it's a
long clock but i don't know if you've
ever worn a scor
skirt before oh yes i have yeah of
course yes
well then then you should know how
freeing it is it's freeing for the uh
for the blessing as they say
as i say well you've named yours the
blessing
i love it i love it
that could get awkward at thanksgiving
dinner
we gotta go relieve the blessing well
it's time for the blessing
[Laughter]
i complimented you there i made a big
moment you did i appreciate it like it
was a lot of that
you broke the table